olá eu estava contar comigo porque na
experiência e convosco e então eu estava
com se inscrevessem nesse país que nos
foram dados
é um pequeno prazo uma palavra clipe os
pincéis bancos quiser sorrir hoje
durante o dia tanto eu também vou
escrever em frança
e enquanto você escreve pois damos
início à apresentação tão bom
meu nome é martin é tem 40 anos o
diretor de criação de uma agência em
lisboa que mandei uma princesa que a
maioria está aqui atrás de mim e é
instalado o projeto de lei que o projeto
catar e da força do impacto das
condições para estarmos sempre está em
nossa vida
acontece que em 2011 quando o mundo na
van mas era ocupada com uma série de
acontecimentos que transcendiam como a
crise financeira ou o wall street a
mesma visita do presidente para a copa
no brasil é um país com uma situação na
minha vida que alterou um pouco meu dia
a dia e as minhas rotinas
acontece que eu digo se a e te permitem
investigar a casa e fazer o jantar é pôr
a mesa brincar com minha filha e não nos
faz eu ia sozinho na noite em que
contava com minha filha a pensar no que
quer a minha velocidade 1 como eu queria
encontrar a minha velocidade e também
acrescentei muito mal e mesmo terceira
casa com uma filha pequena e só porque
queria encontrar a minha velocidade e
então está aí uma conclusão que a
maneira que eu tinha para encontrar na
sociedade e para me sentir muito nem
mesmo o único que tem que fazer é tão
simples como mudar o mundo
se conseguisse mudar um dia sermos o
mais feliz e me sentindo superbem
próprio é quando eu fui pois de pensar
temos e temos enfim cheguei à conclusão
e não queria conseguir melhorar muito
porque eu sozinho eu não consigo deixar
de fumar não consegui cedo
mais arrumado não consegue mudar a minha
maneira de ser
para encarar a vida
inventou a encarar as coisas de outra
maneira não queria conseguir mudar o
mundo mas a verdade é que eu sempre fui
muito captura e pequenos projetos
projetos comuns
abraços grátis ou mais amor por favor
vários projetos dos improvável eram
projetos como tocavam e que deixavam
pensar pela noite tendo como origem boas
e coisas boas no mundo e por outras
pessoas e de forma totalmente inocentes
anderson só porque sim eu achava isso
fantástico crime contaram que na
história a história do dono
a onu era um colega meu que trabalhava
comigo e um pesava uns 180 quilos do dia
23 para o dia mas eu nunca vi ninguém
militantes que fez como num fumava
passar os dias a jogar consola youtube
utiliza nem motor nem pensava comigo não
estava vivo e que era possível aquela
pessoa está viva
acontece que o nome de um dia pro outro
resolveu é passar a ter uma vida mais
saudável então um dia ou outro nicho
tuma deixou de ver a pessoa fazer
exercício físico e só comia salada e o
que aconteceu foi extraordinário por um
propósito e tal
o corpo de luz não aguentou aquela
mudança não fechou
o médico explicou que se eu quisesse é
fazer essa alteração na sua vida e fazer
aos poucos nele
a pouco e pouco primeiro deixar a turma
pois então deixar o benfica fez passar a
ter uma alimentação mais saudável
hoje em dia não tava então ótimo cassol
tem uma filha linda emagreceu conseguir
tudo isso porque as coisas dele da mesma
maneira que o não conseguir mudar o seu
estilo de vida é de um dia para o outro
eu não iria conseguir nunca mudaram o
mundo lhe para o outro as coisas teriam
que ser feitas não querem cada vez e um
dia é ver o filme da aml pollan para mim
como a cena em que ela decida alterar o
dia a dia das pessoas que estão à volta
dela
os vizinhos amigos familiares etc
então eu acho que isso é a cara do
projeto experiência exatamente aquilo
que eu queria fazer era mudar um carinho
o dia a dia das pessoas estavam à minha
volta e então crie uma coisa chamada o
projeto ele basicamente são o fino
projetava eles são pequenas ações que
tenham como objetivo mudar o mundo mas
de uma forma muito simples são pequenas
ações que tenham como objetivo fazer o
eles riram assim isso vai entrando
senhoria e fui fazendo alguns projetos e
algumas ideias todas as equipas
mostraram em mel em uma carta é uma
empresa que rolou estacionamento em
lisboa
e toda a gente já tem com os fiscais os
fiscais mudam os carros e bloqueiam os
carros e betão mas eu só fazia o
trabalho de deus então eu achei que era
simpático deixar cartas aos fiscais é
dizer que cumpriu montado e que não
tinha mais dinheiro então todos os dias
deixava uma carta de frente sempre com
aquela expectativa de pensar o hospital
santa casa e gravatas maneira de
participar não fazia idéia um look da
amazônia deixa cartas todos os dias
deixam de graça é essa coisa que o mação
me uma carta minha presença é ter um
impacto positivo e que fizesse com o
fiscal e meros amy rice um carinho é e
conversassem sobre o que e como isto
isto não impediu que o carro fosse
bloqueado com óbvio não tiveram qualquer
piada até mesmo colocar é da mesma
maneira quando vendia carros nunca uma
carta escondida dentro do quarto do
carro a escolhida a explicar o seu carro
e os links para a próxima pessoa fosse o
carro e fui fazendo as coisas que ajuda
um bairro em lisboa
eu morava então resolvi transformar o
nome do bairro um título ajuda com este
evento a todos os dias com ele para casa
passava por este profissional de ajuda
não se pode fazer muito mais sentido de
soja e fui mensagens colhidas de casa
lembrar às pessoas que não é proibido
por onde treinam é preciso não é
proibido abraçar alguém fazer alguma
coisa boa por outra pessoa mas que em
proibido esquecer os amigos ou proibido
esquecer o amor
então fui desenvolvendo essas
organizações casos nos banheiros com
água o carro dos pais a dizer hoje está
muito bonita o estádio bonito no auge da
crise a caixa eletrônico
pois estas frases e dizer para as
pessoas lembrarem que eram mais do que o
extrato bancário que sair a senha da
máquina e distribuiu elogios e um
sem-fim coisas que fui fazer ao longo do
tempo
foi engraçado que aconteceu aqui foi
extraordinário foi campeão as pessoas
começaram a ligar o meu projeto e as
pessoas começaram a perguntar como é que
iam fazer isso nas cidades delas quebrou
implementar estes poderiam copiar o rio
claro que sim podem criar o projeto
vocês fazerem fizerem isto é nós estamos
sem relações com as pessoas votando o
projeto foi crescendo e hoje em dia já
está em portugal inteiro tá em espanha a
imprensa tá na argentina e está agora
aqui no brasil e aqui em blumenau com
muita força e foi extraordinário aquela
ideia que eu tinha de mudar o mundo e
que achava completamente impossível nem
sequer consigo deixar de fumar ou
arrumar a casa com descer e queria mudar
o mundo realmente acontecido e então já
não era estava a mudar o mundo era toda
do exército gente que estava à volta do
projecto é fazer isso comigo de forma
independente como criam copiavam
mensagens o criavam de próprias
mensagens com isso realmente ou eu
acredito cônsul dar um carrinho mundo
vai manter uma conversa muito séria e
criticou eu digo eu tenho direito da
universidade cujo todos nós temos
direito a nossa sociedade e todos nós
procuramos a nossa funcionária que
acontece nesse procura da nossa paz irá
a uma coisa que vai acontecer de certeza
que nós vamos ser o guarda sol no centro
pratos com desgosto com aquele é muito
grande é da mesma
vamos falhar e nesse olhar com pessoas a
falar com pais ou maridos ou namorados o
que for necessário dizer que nós
sentimos uma injustiça muito grande
sentimos que o mundo não está a ser
feliz na única coisa que deve ser feliz
é muito repentino nos deixa quando
falhamos nos sentimos que a nossa
autoestima pode ser muito e sentimos que
não temos o direito de fazer aquilo que
conhecemos a novidade nesse caminho e
vamos entregar a nossa funciona e o que
eu aprendi é neste caminho que concentra
na praça para de funcionar porque esses
pequenos - estas pequenas coisas que eu
faço repente vamos ganhar coisas
em 11 e fazendo banho-maria e que gosto
de pensar que mesmo que eu já senti mal
lo
ok tá muito magoado com o mundo é e usar
ganha sorrir e okami que entretanto vão
receber esse ponto e vou por isso eu vou
preciso rir este cliente é ajudam muito
a seu é ultrapassar esses obstáculos é
no caminho da nossa sociedade
se vocês pensarem bem é tão simples
mudar o mundo é tão simples estas
pequenas ações para temos de fazer todos
os dias durante os dia existem nas
oportunidades para mudarmos o mundo seja
abrir a porta para a primária ou dar um
gato segmento outra pessoa seja carregar
as compras do idoso vai alguém de seu
chapéu de chuva observa uma moça quem
precisa deixar casa da namorada ou
namorado a dizer um bonito que o chão e
os importantes são a nossa vida
quero trabalhar até mais tarde para quem
possui casa brincar com a família
eu já era um amigo e eu acho que os
indíos nós temos falado aqui muito
sorridente obrigados e pedisse desculpa
e do agradecimento eu acho que hoje
também é uma ferramenta fundamental na
sociedade e os germes a ganhar uma coisa
que tem um impacto muito positivo na
vida das pessoas e todas essas coisas
juntas permitem nos mandaram que ninguém
no mundo que está à nossa volta
queria terminar e com três conclusões
muito simples e que explicamos como é
que estão throw é um modo de ver a
primeira coisa que ao viver assim
alcançar isso um projeto tão simples
como apresentar meu livro foi traduzido
ações que estamos em duas competições
criam por um projeto assinado delas ou
criam né
será sempre um piano ou só uma mensagem
de agradecimento disse que foram paradas
com qualquer coisa e nessas posições
inclusivamente compõem terem combinado
atravessar o atlântico quinta era ficar
falar com vocês conhecer esta gente
fantástica a equipe fantástica e está
entendendo o numeral e conhecer os
piscas todos já ouvimos todos e criam se
as relações em dia não conseguia
explicar que anunciaram no facebook
e quando a conclusão é que ele descobre
voltar a falar no painel para um dia diz
que é fascinado com uma tristeza é não
faz nem dos grandes - considerado um dos
grandes momentos de tristeza
quer dizer que nós durante a nossa vida
nos surpreende
gosto dos filmes gosto muito grande
todos nós seja mortal ganho o modo de
vida da nossa vida que nos deixa é uma
doença grave que a de qualquer coisa nós
vamos prender esses gostos na nossa vida
da mesma maneira que vamos ter grandes
momentos considerados e quer um caso que
no outro é isso não termina a nossa vida
com uma vida feliz com minha vida em
flins dar um exemplo eu poderia dizer
que o nascimento da minha filha que está
aqui tenha sido o momento mais feliz da
minha vida mas não foi muito mais
importante em todos os momentos que
passei com ela todos o espírito que
passei com ela desde que ela nasceu do
que o dia do seu nascimento
então se vocês pensarem isso é muito
importante nós ligamos as pequenas
coisas ligarmos o os pequenos - que nos
podem trazer velocidade e construirmos a
nossa funcionado muito mais através
desse entendimento do que se espera de
um grande momento funciona e última
conclusão que eu escreva santa a nas
vossas mãos e o que eu queria que vocês
fizessem era que ele pegasse inscreveram
na prova mas que estavam a ouvir hoje e
passar sem pagar em próximo vocês
é bom vê los todos que ainda assim
e esta é a mensagem mais importante que
eu posso passar e que ao se conectarem
assim de uma forma positiva com quem
está perto de vocês vocês próprios
creche e ao mesmo tempo que ajuda uma
das outras pessoas é que xerém ea
carteira funcional dentre vocês então
que os convidados a fazer era
experimentar em viver a vossa funcionar
através do funcional dos outros
abria